hello everyone thanks for joining
and uh welcome to this uh session
let's get started so my talk is about a
software that we developed examine here
and how we do deeply randomized
assessment with it so let's go ahead and
get started
and i'm going to first tell you a little
bit about myself where i come from what
i do
and how we started getting involved in
this kind of work
and how will from language flows plays a
role into this
so a little bit about me i'm a faculty
at
department of physics at indian
institute of science education and
research
at bhopal in india and i joined
iac or bhopal in 2012
before this i did a postdoc at carnegie
mellon university
from 2009 to 2012 uh i did my phd in
theatrical high energy physics at mit
i graduated in class of 2009 i did my
masters of physics
in india at institute of technology in
kanpur
these days my main activities are
teaching physics
doing research in physics and
mathematics doing software development
and working in various aspects of
education technology
my research mainly deals with the
quantum chromodynamics jet physics
and these days i'm also looking at graph
theory and applications of machine
learning
also uh in 2015
at isr bropal
we founded a center for research in
advanced technology for education and
science everybody that it creates
and this is where we do our education
technology development
and this is where we have developed the
software examiner that i'm going to
tell you about the website of the
of of the center is over here so i would
welcome you to check it out at some time
because in this talk i'm not going to
tell you
much about what we do at the center but
i will just be focusing on one aspect of
the center
which is the development of examiner and
how we
use wolfram language innovatively
with the examiner so that was a little
bit about
me uh
about icer institute of science
education research
this is a very new institution it has
only been around for 12 years it was
established in 2008.
we have about only 2000 students about
you know 600 to 700 of them are phd
students rest of them are
undergraduates uh we have only 150
faculty members we have a small campus
rather
only about 80 hectares uh we've got ug
and grad
school uh in basic sciences engineering
sciences economics
and data sciences so as i said we're you
know we're a fairly small institution
we are not very diverse we are very
focused uh
we do a lot of research and a lot of
teaching
recently we have been ranked 26 among
the top 100 young universities that is
the universities and
institutions which has come up in last
50 years
according to nature index ranking of
2019 also in india we are among the top
50 universities
according to the national indian ranking
here's a
bird's eye view of the campus so
this is our academic block which is
where all the academic activity happens
now in my work i have been using wolfram
technologies
in various aspects
i started using mathematica as a
graduate student when i was at mit and
i've used it extensively during my phd
and postdoc so i've been
you know you've been i've been using
mathematica since 2003
and wolf from language i've been using
for research a lot
and i use it with symbolic computing
data analysis machine learning
graph theory so you know uh i've
my training in phd and their their
option research
i've been using well from language and
mathematica a lot
so that is my background with
mathematica
and you know since 2012 when i joined
iso bhopal after i came back from us and
joined
isopropyl i've been using mathematica
and wolfe from language also for
teaching
also recently we have co-created an
undergraduate course called
physics through computational thinking
this is i've done in collaboration with
my colleague
aditya sharma who is a faculty also at
isobopa
and we have been extensively using
wolfram language for teaching
computational thinking
through this course we use examples in
physics
to teach this course also since 2015
uh i've been using work from language
for education technology development
uh this is where we have used will from
language to create
exam here which is an assessment
platform for higher education
uh this is again as i said it's a work
done under the center that
we established in terms of 2015. so for
about last four
point five years we've been doing
development for examining
and this is where uh you know all my
uh background that i had with
mathematica and wolfram language doing
in research
it inspired me to eventually use it for
software development for assessment and
that's what i'm going to tell you about
today
so examiner before i start talking about
examiner and you know technical aspects
of it
i want to tell you a little story so
that you get a perspective of
why he started doing this when i moved
back to india in 2012
i started teaching and uh you know
i would be teaching a class of 80
students pretty much
at the time we were very young
institutions only five years old or
something
and we had no teaching assistants and we
have
to prepare for lectures present the
lectures
after that we have to give regular
assignments and homeworks
then once the students summit we don't
have any support for grading so we would
be grading them ourselves
so this is where we started realizing
the challenge
of teaching in india or higher education
academics in india
the challenge we face often is we have a
large number of students
very few faculty pretty much no tas
now that we have some graduations we are
getting some teaching assistance
to help us out with teaching activities
but mostly
uh in lots of colleges in india
all if you leave the premier
institutions top ranking institutions
out
most of the colleges in india higher
education institutions in india
do not have teaching support in fact in
some of the institutions
some of the faculty have to teach you
know two or three courses sometimes even
five courses
and when they have to teach so much
assessment is something that is often
left out so that's one challenge uh that
it is expected from us to give regular
homeworks
when the students submit the homeworks
we have to grade it so assessment is a
challenge
for us to uh do and this is where we
needed a software or some sort of
technological solution which can help us
in doing assessment the second challenge
related to assessment that we feel in
india
is we have large classes almost
no support so at the end of the day
a lot of students start copying homework
from each other and they don't even
realize that
what they're doing and this is something
that i realized when i joined here as a
faculty and i started teaching
and i realized that i really do not have
time to
find out whether students are cheating
or not whether they're copying their
homework from somebody
else or not so how do i test and find
out whether
they're actually doing work themselves
or they're copying from somebody else
so then i started figuring out solutions
thinking about how we can
uh find a technological solution which
can help in doing this
and as a first activity what i started
doing is when i realized that
some of the students were copying the
exams uh and
to be honest i felt that it was not
really their fault
because they never really understood the
importance of homeworks
when they were in schools they did not
quite realize
all they had a task that they had to
submit the homework to the teacher
and as a consequence what they were
doing was they were just copying the
homeworks from somebody and submitting
it and teachers were
giving them full score so they did not
even realize what was the importance of
doing original work
so when these friends come to higher
education suddenly we start to teach
them or appreciate
them when they start to do original work
or we criticize them when they do not do
original work
and moreover it's a lot of challenge for
us to find out who is doing original
work and who is not doing original work
so this is where we started facing
challenge
and mostly in examinations when we found
out that a lot of students were
were copying from each other so i really
thought uh really felt that this was not
really a fault of students we never
really gave
them an honest opportunity to do some
honest work
so one of the things early in the days
what i started doing was because of my
familiarity with exa
with mathematica and world from language
i started generating uh
you know notebooks in which there will
be individualized question paper for
each student
which should be actually the number code
and we'll generate the answer key
according to that number code so we'll
hand out these question papers for to
each of the strings randomly in the
class
so each one will have a distinct
question paper generated out of a
mathematica notebook and they will
answer or check mark the questions uh
multiple choice questions or fill in the
blank questions
they will do a lot of that the summit
will use the keys that you have
generated
to grade that manually so that worked
out very well for me
but i realized that this was something
that requires
you know extensive knowledge of working
with language and most of the
people who are not familiar most of my
colleagues were not familiar and if i
go outside my institution a lot of the
people outside the institutions were not
familiar in other colleges so then this
idea started to develop that if i could
create
a software platform uh which could
exactly
do this that is it generates
individualized question paper for each
student
testing the same concepts but everyone
gets a different set of questions
so that is defined organization so how
we generate
examinations or assessment for students
so that each one of them
get a different question paper so that
they cannot really copy from each other
and they are
forced to do honest work by themselves
so this is where examiner started
and that's why we started building this
uh software that is why
that was what was my inspiration and
initially in you know first of all of
years i thought that you know eventually
somebody someone will do it
there are so many software companies
eventually someone will come forth and
do it
and then after some time i started
really feeling that this is something we
need to do
and then fortunately we got funding
support from ministry of education
at that time it was called ministry of
uh human resource development
uh and that with that funding we
established the center and we started
doing this
software development so here's my reason
of choosing wolfram language for
developing examiner
world from language is a complete
package for mathematics and computation
uh everyone here is familiar with
wolfram language so i don't have to
describe that
one of the beautiful things about
wolfram language is that
there's an automated interpretation of
mathematical expressions there are
functions
uh which are interpreted mathematically
and they're computed mathematically
i can do symbolic computation i can do
numerical calculations and
even i can once i've done the numerical
calculation or once i've done the
symbolic computation
i can go ahead and output that as a tech
or mathematical output
both of these outputs are suitable for
web applications
so wolfram language is providing me a
complete package for deep randomization
for assessment and we have already done
that
uh through the notebooks now what we
wanted to do was we wanted to translate
that from notebooks
to and then convert them into pdfs to
directly to put it in the web
so that these deep randomized assessment
content can be delivered to the students
through web technologies
they answer the questions on the web it
gets graded automatically
they get the immediate feedback so that
when the when they get the immediate
feedback after doing their quiz
the you know what they have done is
fresh in their minds so they want to
learn from it they'll go back and check
they'll find out their mistakes they'll
come and discuss with teachers
usually when we are doing a paper-based
test we get it back we grade it
we give it back and it usually takes
long time it sometimes takes several
weeks and when that happens
they've forgotten what they did at the
time in the test or in the homework and
in that process they do they
the desire to learn because they've
already forgotten what they did
so immediate feedback is very very
useful and this is where we thought
that you know doing this through a web
technology and automatic
grading will really be useful so that's
where wolfram language comes in
and i'll give you some idea of how we
are using wolfram language
to do this so what is multi-layer deep
randomization
um so there are a few different layers
of randomization that pretty much any
assessment platform
especially after this kovid 19 era uh we
are all the teachers we have you know
started some using some sort of lms or
some sort of
assessment software for you know
conducting online quizzes even if it is
just google forms now uh
so when there's certain randomization
that is available
pretty much in all these uh platforms
whether it's moodle whether it's
blackboard whether it's canvas
and some of these basic randomization
techniques are randomized the question
selection
so if i give you 20 questions and uh you
can select 10
randomly for each trend and deliver to
them so that everyone gets a different
set of 10 questions
that's one way of randomization another
way of randomization you randomize the
order of questions
so that they cannot compare which square
you know at which number
i have gotten a certain question which
number they've got a certain question so
it makes it a little difficult for them
to
find out and tally with each other
especially when you know when you have
no initialization at all
the third way of randomization is
selecting the
uh items or randomizing the order of the
options again
this is something that is available in
all platforms so where examiner stands
apart from all of them is deep
randomization
where we do de-randomization of content
through parameterization
and computable mathematics what that
means is that everyone is delivered the
same question
where they uh you know the same concept
is being tested
but we change the uh content internally
some of the numbers are changed some of
the numbers are randomized so the
functions can be randomized
images can be randomized so the kind of
randomization we can do
with computable mathematics and work
from language capabilities
is that we are able to uh you know
do arbitrary parameterization and
arbitrary de-randomization
so it's not just limited to numbers it
can be expressions it can be images
all of those things so this is how we
actually implement uh wolfram language
we have created a computable math
language called mingo
which is the language for front end and
in something this is inspired a lot by
you know wolfram language
tech and ascii math these are you know
some of the languages
for mathematics now ascii math is just
representation
of math tech is representation of
math it's it's negative mathematics so
both tech and ascii method
narrative mathematics wolfram language
is something that is
both computable and can also be used for
narrative maths
so we start we we designed you know a
much larger version
of such a language a computable language
called bingo
which is compiled in the backend and
evaluated by wolfram language
compiler and it is
you know it is evaluated and computed to
prop give a properly typeset
mathematical output which is what is
rendered on the
web browser so i'll give you a
demonstration of that in a moment
now what authors do is authors means the
teachers
we give accounts to the teachers
teachers create on the front end
they create the content with narrative
text and mingle to create assessment
content bingo is a computable language
so if they put in a formula that gets
computed uh now
authors when they type expressions in
mango
they also set some parameters these
parameters
can be numbers these parameters can be
expressions
and these are images even functions and
they are substituted into mingo
expressions
during the evaluation and the
substitutions are random so every time
a unique content is generated for a user
and this is what we call as deep
randomization
in the back end we have a full from
language in web mathematica
which is used to compile and create
assessment content and quizzes
wolfram language we also use for grading
quizzes so this is
the component of the wolfram language in
the background
and i'm now going to show you
demonstration so
let me just quickly uh go to the browser
here
so here's a quiz that i've recently
taken for my participants this is the
quiz management page which shows you
know how much progress they have made
made when did the summit uh how how much
score they got so this is
this is live updated but that is not uh
that doesn't uh
you know involve wolfram technology so
here's a
uh a student's quiz so this is where you
see
uh this is a quiz the restaurant has
taken
and you know this is an arrangement
question where you know some space time
points are given and they have to
arrange them in the order of uh
i believe this is uh in the
chronological order of occurrence in a
certain relativistic frame
and similarly so this arrangement
question here is an example of a fill in
the blank question and you see
you know there is a value here which is
random for each student
there's a value here that is random for
each string and as a consequence
this answer that they have to calculate
is random for each student and
also you know you can see the class
statistics
and student can compare how he's done he
has you know worked
in comparison to the class again here's
another fill in the blank question
here's a multiple choice question and
you see you know there are
some numbers here which get randomized
we can set those numbers
and let me show you an example here so
i think this is this is a question so if
i
so this is the question so you see this
is a you know i fill in the blank
question i can give some instruction
and this is where my question is and
this is where computable math goes
so this is mingo this is computable math
goes in this mode
so it's much like latex you can you know
type write narrative text
and then you can write uh some uh
computable maps in uh mingo and then
uh this is compiled in a wolfram
language compiler in the backend
and after that the content is generated
and if i do a give five and
you know i also set up the answer key
answer key is some sort of computation
which is defined in terms of this
variable called answer
and this answer is defined over here
it's calculated in terms of parameters a
and b
and you know the parameters a and b are
defined over here
as various things so this a can be any
of these values
so any one of these values can be chosen
randomly and
b is any one of these values chosen
randomly i can also
correlate a and p so when a certain
value of a is chosen
i can choose certain value of b and so
on so if i do a gif 5 over here i'll
generate 5 random instances of
this question so in this particular
instance a is one by four and b is one
by four and i get
this question and corresponding the
answer as a certain range
and uh
and i see you know this is the second
instance again the parameters has
changed and correspondingly the question
the answer has changed
and over here another set of parameters
and the
you know the question has changed the
answer range has changed so this is how
it works and you know i can define
parameter as lists
ranges or you know i can correlate them
using a set of
group parameters so all of those things
are possible i can also define some
definitions and include those
definitions
in the part of the question or part of
the answer
so this was fill in the blank question
here is an example of a multiple choice
question again
there are a bunch of parameters that are
defined over here
and let me show you one more so here
this is the authentic portal this is
where
people create content that is teachers
create content is an example of a
arrangement question where some items
are given
they have a value that is evaluated
automatically with the formula
so for example over here this is my
statement
of the item and these are the
corresponding values
okay i see there are some questions so
let me just wrap this up and then i'll
look at the questions so
this um this is how i can you know
program for each of these items what is
the value that that is going to evaluate
to
and when the students arrange these
items uh the system automatically checks
and whether the values are arranged in
the increasing order
or decreasing order and you select the
order from here and if they're
properly arranged in increasing order
decreasing order they're automatically
graded as
as correct or incorrect so let me come
back to so that was a quick demo
and i see there are a couple of
questions let me just look at those
questions how students access this
platform is it integrated with something
as lms at your university so this is uh
accessible at this site called
examiner.in so if i just open
a browser and just type examiner.n it
loads up the
you know login page for students and
there are two tabs here the student tab
and author tab
and authors can request an account
students don't need accounts when a quiz
is created by the authors
their accounts are generated
automatically so they don't need any
accounts and this is where
you know teachers can log in and access
the platform this is what the platform
looks like
this is my uh dashboard and you know i
to create content various kinds of
content i can create from here
and i can you know create a library of
committed content and this library of
community content i can pick and choose
what i want to use in my next quiz and
so on
so that was a quick demo um i don't have
time to show all the features in detail
but i just wanted to give you an idea of
how we're using wolfram language
so now i'll just quickly go over in next
few minutes
features of examiner so an exam here we
have got
four or five different kinds of
assessment contents we have multiple
choice questions
arrangement and order items fill in the
blanks and
we have got you know subjective
questions and with assisted grading
which is something we are
still working on and all these questions
can contain any kind of media we can
have vector images embed anywhere in the
question you can have it in
in the question you can have it in the
options so whether it's a vector it's a
bitmap image whether it's a video
it's a pdf file whether it's a data
chart all of these can be embedded
anywhere in the content
whether it's informational content or
the assessment content
so there are a couple more questions let
me take those questions
and seeing some questions on pathable
what is the student interface like is
there a palette where they can insert
maths without knowledge of full from
language
gestures don't need to know will from
language uh in subjective questions they
can actually insert maths using latex or
ascii math
and the student interface actually just
looks like this
so this is the student interface
actually this is this is a particular
student who's
who has already taken this quiz and i'm
showing you after the quiz what it looks
like
during the quiz they were able to select
one of these mcq options or
they were able to you know fill the
blank in uh
during the quiz and after the quiz this
is what it looks like
there's one more question uh by milan
are there any plans to use this
assistant platform in other institutions
is there any website with examples and
documentation
so we are using uh across multiple
higher education institutions
in india we have not really launched it
outside india but we can do it for
you know a few people who are interested
in trying it out uh
right now we are just you know we are
just giving accounts to faculty in india
and it's really easy to sign up if you
go
to the examiner.n click on the author
tab and if you request for an account
you know you can fill out this little
form and we can provide accounts for you
again this will be like in the trial
mode for outside india
so we are not really promoting right now
outside out outside india but eventually
we'll start working with
institutions out of india also
is there a website with documentation
yes if you
again if we go back to this page there
is a little link
here read the docs and the docs we have
given detailed documentation of how to
work with the platform there are also
video tutorials
to learn how to create content and also
a detailed
documentation about how to use mingo
that is the language that we have
created
so coming back to uh so again coming
back to languages
uh i think i have just about three
minutes so
coming back to languages we have support
for all the languages
it's whether it's english or you know
spanish or french
any of the languages which are supported
by unicode standard are supported that
is
uh in simple words anything that is
supported by google keyboard
is also supported on examiner we can do
equation type setting using
tech and ascii math which are just
narrative mathematics
and also with mingo which is powered by
wolfram language in the background
and this is computable mathematics uh
we can do some kind of content markup
through html tags
our tech stack is actually um very
modern scalable we use angularjs and
bootstrap in the front end
nginx
server and load balancer use node.js for
uh back-end uh services uh web services
and the backend is powered by wolfram
language versus where we do all the
intelligent things that is we you know
compile the content over there
we create generate the quizzes which are
deeply randomized
and our database is no sql database so
uh the
the node.js and all from language talk
to each other and then we have got
uh node.js and couchdb talk to each
other well from language and culturally
talk to each other
and enginex works is a proxy server for
node.js and it delivers these services
to the front end
so that's our text stack uh we have got
synchronous quizzes which is
live quizzes you can give uh you can
push same the same same content to all
the students simultaneously
you can also push a live stream through
youtube live
there are some certain constraints that
youtube live applies if those
constraints are not there then you can
push that
content you can include a chat or
whiteboard you can see the live statuses
of the class
uh and and you see here this is uh the
live status of the class you can see
you know studies of the class you can
also share the studies with the class
you can also tell them whether they've
answered the question correctly or not
so this is really great for formative
assessment
and then we have asynchronous quizzes
and lessons which are really great for
uh summative assessment you can embed a
video anywhere so here's an example of
informational content where a video is
embedded and also pdf file is embedded
so that students can
watch the video refer to the pdf file
and then follow up
they can they can you know work on some
questions based on those videos so this
is the lesson mode
uh then you can have you know testing
i've already shown you some examples of
that
you can provide elaborate instructions
you can design a flexible grading matrix
you can do detailed performance uh
summary and analytics
also you have got detailed quiz
management features where
you know we have got detailed quiz
properties
control quiz sessions live tracking of
student activities you can collaborate
with other teachers and creating quizzes
you can distribute passwords either
through emails or on paper
you can download performance summary
report and all of these features
actually provide you you know detailed
control over the class and therefore
you can do a crisis management uh very
efficiently
so as i've mentioned voltron language is
really really
you know the core of it it's the soul of
the system it powers mingo
the computable math language that we use
it powers deep randomization it
generates
individualized quizzes and also creates
quizzes for students
that's where the wolfram language comes
in and examiner so far we've only
released it in india
we have uh 850 authors 7000 contents
created 1300 quizzes
we have 38 000 quiz users out of which
10 000 are unique quiz users
and uh 64 000 quiz sections have been uh
delivered so a summary and looking ahead
uh without fulfilling language
and without experience with language and
without its capabilities we could not
have comprehend
examine here and we would have not
thought of doing
deeply randomized assessments in the way
we are doing it uh
in the future we want to build adaptive
testing using item response theory
use ai to evaluate subjective content
and reach out to wider
user base globally
finally this is my team so most of these
people are developers they work on
various web technologies
uh some of them are managers project
managers which
do very various kind of management tasks
and in this
team is also this lady
who's my wife and she has done a lot of
beta testing for us
on examiner uh she's a math teacher and
she has used
all her math skills to test various
kinds of things
so finally i would
wrap up my talk by acknowledging the
world from technology conference team
for giving me an opportunity to present
here
i also give special thanks to abel
who introduced me to welcome technology
conference and
finally i thank ministry of human
resource development
of government of india under which under
the national mission on teachers in
teaching
supported the funding for this
particular event and i thank
institution my institution iso bhopal
for hosting
this application so thank you for
joining me today and if there are any
more questions i'll be very very happy
to take them
i think there was a follow-up question
what courses are using examining
examiner now
uh so we use it for pretty much
everything so
i i have used it for physics some of my
colleagues who use this for mathematics
and chemistry and then even english
teachers have used it
and in other institutions i have no idea
but uh definitely there are ancient
faculty who are using it
there are humanities faculty who are
using it there are biology faculty who
are using it so
uh all kinds of people from all uh
spectrum
are using examiner right now
thanks mats for your comment
thanks everyone and once more abel
thanks a lot for
bringing me here to work from technology
conference i see you are
one of the attendees so once again
thanks a lot